hi my name is dina fenan and i'm a
product manager at 10x genomics
um today i have the privilege of giving
a short introduction before
sort of an overview of our technology
before my colleague stephen williams
takes it away to tell a story with some
interesting data
so i'm sure you're all no doubt well
aware that human biology is immensely
complex
a significant amount of research has
obviously been done already to
uncover all of these complexities but
there's still just so much left to
discover
so from the trillions of cells that make
up our bodies encompassing many
different cell types
the genes encoded in our dna the
structure of the chromatin
and the transcription and translation of
all the genes you know depending on the
cell types
there's just so many different layers of
complexity there
so at 10x we develop tools to try to
resolve this complexity
and it's our mission to continue to push
the technology boundaries to offer
solutions to accelerate your research
around this our solutions really span
the whole process as depicted in this
slide from the assays and the
biochemistry behind them
to the instruments down to the powerful
analysis and visualization tools
um in terms of software so the core of
the way we address this complexity is to
use barcoding
and that allows you to maintain the
identity of single cells
single regions of interest on a tissue
or single features
while still allowing you to process a
lot of samples in bulk
and so i you know even before the last
couple of months where it's become
painfully clear to the world
how um how important it is to gain
deeper understanding of biology
um the whole you know the last few years
have really just been a golden era in
terms of
speeding up discovery across across life
science
um so single cell sequencing has
actually been an engine that's driven
a lot of this research that's been
published in a lot of top-notch journals
over the last few years in 2019 we
actually saw
more than one publication per day using
our solutions at 10x for a total of over
700 papers
and these publications really cover an
incredible range of research areas from
oncology to immunology
and developmental biology and
neuroscience among others
so to give you an introduction or a
recap depending on your familiarity with
our workflows
for single cell work the carefully
integrated instrument
the consumables and the reagents they
take you all the way from a single cell
suspension
your sample to sequencing ready
libraries
and on the other end of the sequencing
the analysis and visualization pipelines
take you from fast q files to reduce
data and give you some biological
insight into those samples
so as i mentioned earlier with the
number of publications and just all the
good research
to highlight it's very difficult to
choose just a couple
to focus on so these two papers are just
among my current favorites and so i just
wanted to kind of
bring them up because they both tackle
really complex diseases
so the one on the left is out of ucsf
and the one on the right is out of the
broad institute and both of these are um
like i said
you know tackling extremely complex
diseases
autism and alzheimer's disease and
they're both case controlled studies
that um look at cell type specific
changes in gene expression to get a much
more detailed picture
of the changes that occur in disease
affected tissue
so the types of studies that are done
here i think really highlight
you know if you aren't sure the why of
why to do single cell
research this is really the three
reasons i think that are highlighted
here so number one
you actually learn the cell type that
you're looking at where the change
in gene expression occurred so that's
really critical information
number two you increase your statistical
power because you're comparing
expression levels of cells of the same
type
which makes a lot of sense right when
you're looking at gene expression
in a complex tissue like the brain for
example and then the third thing is you
have the power to distinguish between
changes in expression levels
versus changes in the abundance of cell
types
so these are a couple of like reasons
that i feel like if you haven't
considered some of the reasons to do
single cell
gene expression studies these papers
might change your mind
um so our newer vision platform follows
a similar template as
our single cell and so we leveraged our
experience with the single cell work
to to dramatically improve the
sensitivity and the ease of use of the
spatial transcriptomics platform
so here we adapted our pipeline and our
visualization software as well to be
able to integrate
imaging and molecular data on top of the
sequencing data
and steven's talk i think will really
highlight some of the advantages of
being able to do this
oops okay so um
over the last five years at 10x we've
introduced a whole suite of different
applications
in different areas so i just i've talked
a little bit about the single cell gene
expression
and i wanted to highlight just a couple
of others to call attention to them
so our immune profiling solution allows
you to highlight
to simultaneously examine the cellular
context of the adaptive immune response
and the immune repertoires of anywhere
from hundreds to thousands of
tens of thousands of cells at the same
time so you can look at t cells and b
cells
cell by cell and with the feature bar
coding technology added on top
you can also look simultaneously at
other kinds of cellular readouts
like cell surface proteins and antigen
specificity
which is very powerful and then our
attack seek
in green over here in the middle of the
2018
group um the attack seek solution
enables you to look at chromatin
profiling
of thousands of single cells in parallel
so that um
to kind of advance the understanding of
how chromatin compaction and dna binding
proteins
regulate gene expression at very high
resolution
so these are two really interesting
things that you know have come about
recently at 10x
and you can kind of see how rapidly new
technology is
is being introduced and so with that i
also wanted to say that
you know this year there's a lot more to
come and i think stephen's giving a
little teaser on
um something in the in the vision
platform but
i really encourage you to go to our
website there's this page
future and you can sign up for updates
to stay connected and find out what
exciting things we're doing next
so please stay in touch
hello my name is stephen williams i am a
senior scientist at 10x genomics
in the computational biology department
i want to thank
dina for the nice overview of the
solutions that 10x genomics
has to offer and some of the things that
we're working on down the road
today i'm going to give an overview of
using vision to spatially resolve
triple negative breast cancer
[Music]
so first i'd just like to give a small
overview
of the vision technology so the
aim of visiom is to have unprecedented
uh resolution uh being able to capture
simultaneous analytes and
put them all in complete context while
at the same time doing it
at scale and making it accessible and
easy
for every lab to run any 10x genomics
application
fundamentally the vision spatial
application
is based on a slide that contains
four capture areas each one of these
capture areas contains five thousand
markers
that have a
partial read one a spatial barcode
a umi and a polydt to capture
polyadenylated mrnas each spot
is printed the in the exact same place
every single time
so we know which barcodes go where
and this is what really enables being
able to map
rna expression back to image space
so the spatial gene expression workflow
goes as follows
first you section your tissue on your
normal cryostat that
many labs and hospitals have you do your
vision prep which in first
you take a hne image of your tissue
place it on your capture area do
permeabilization
and then all the mrnas are then captured
by
the oligos that i showed in the in the
slide previously
then you do a standard library prep
sequence
on your favorite sequencer probably
illumina
and then do uh everything is kind of
done for you
from that point on the space range or
pipeline takes care of
all the tissue segmentation
tissue detection and representation and
visualization
of all of your mrnas in
tissue space and this is really enhanced
by the loop browser
that allows you to zoom and do
differential expression
and create custom clusters um
but these outputs from both space ranger
and from loop both can be
uh imported into
community analysis pools such as surat
or monocle
or scampi some of the things that i'll
actually show today
that's with the exception of the c-loop
file
so space ranger is a linux command-line
software
that is used to process the sequencing
data for downstream analysis
automatically aligns tissue and gene
expression data
and detects spots under tissue and
identifies spatial gene expression
patterns
uh cluster spots to facilitate cell type
annotation
with downstream tools and
generates actionable qc metrics on these
very nice
html pages that we produce with every
space ranger run
the loop browser is amazing
and it's got a real upgrade with the
addition of spatial data
so loop is an intuitive desktop
visualization software
that allows you to interactively explore
your data and when i say interactively i
mean really interactively you can
zoom you can pan you can change colors
you can export your data you can import
data
it is really flexible and it's become a
very powerful tool
to use in discovering the underlying
biology
of the experiments that you might run on
visual
but that's not it so coming soon to the
vision platform
we'll be enabling targeted gene
expression immunofluorescence
integration and i'll show some of that
today
feature barcoding technology for things
like feature barcoded antibodies
and enabling solutions for ffpe
so our assay development team has done a
lot of work
on
breaking down the tools and the
processes that are needed
to properly prep a variety of different
tissues from human
mouse and rat actually and you can see
there are a wide variety of human
tissues as well as mouth tissues
but the one that i'll be speaking about
today
is breast tissue in the context of
triple negative breast cancer so i'm
going to just give a
brief overview of triple negative breast
cancer
so triple negative breast cancer is a
devastating disease as many of you know
but the specific phenotype for triple
negative breast cancer is that
these individual tumors are negative for
estrogen receptors progesterone
receptors and
excess her2 protein expression
the burden of triple negative breast
cancer on
our society as a whole is tremendous
this is a very aggressive disease that
accounts for
10 to 20 percent of all breast cancer
cases that are diagnosed
in the united states annually and what
makes this
disease very tough is that it's
resistant to conventional therapies
which leads typically to a poor
prognosis
so understanding the underlying biology
and the micro environment
of each individual person's triple
negative breast cancer
is essential to improve diagnosis and
therapeutic outcome
so first i'd like to give an overview of
the molecular design of our study
we obtained two tumors
from middle-aged female cases and we
purchased them from
biowave ivt and
these individuals are from diverse
ancestry
they have high grade tumors so grade
three
and we did a lot of work on these tumors
we took serial sections and ran them on
busium at least
three sections for each version
of the workflow that we did first we did
the standard brazilian workflow
h e staining with follow-up with
capture of mrnas then we did
each of these hne stained images was
sent to a pathologist who
annotated them as well then we did
integration with immunofluorescence
using cd3 and cd8
protein antibodies and i'll be showing
some of the cd3 data today and then we
also ran
uh these vision samples on
our targeted pan cancer panel which will
be coming out later this year
i'm not going to show any of that
information but i can say that it worked
great
and it's a fantastic way to lower your
sequencing costs
if you know what you're looking for
we also paired both of these
tumors with single nuclei rna sequencing
data
so from each individual tumor we
obtained
approximately 40 000 single nuclei
making a
a metadata set of approximately
880 000 single nuclei
and these were annotated by one of our
expert scientists at 10x genomics
so now i'd like to talk about our study
overview from the computational
perspective
um so we did a variety of different
things
a lot of which was custom but all done
uh with the basis being the standard
with vision workflow
so we did differential gene expression
in space this was done
with space ranger not cell ranger
we did integration and correlation of
clustering with pathologist annotations
these were imported into r and plotted
on top
of our vision images we used these to do
custom clustering and differential gene
expression
we did quantification of fluorescence
intensity
and this was performed with r as well
we use these intensities to do
custom clustering and differential
expression in loop again
and this gives us insights into cell
type specific behavior
we also use the surat package to
identify
spatially variable features or genes and
we integrated
single nuclei rna sequencing data with
steroids
to identify cell type specific
expression pattern invisi
so now i'll give a uh intro to
the vision technology and our basic
analysis
using space ranger
so fundamentally the vision
assay is powered by an h e tissue
section
capturing that mrna putting it through
the space ranger pipeline and
outputting really nice information that
you can
explore and loop and all of this is
pre-packaged in
a very easy to use workflow
the typical output of a space ranger run
will be your you'll be able to visualize
your h
e sample in space you will then
be able to visualize mrna expression
on top of your h e image and each one of
these spots represents one of the
printed spots on the
capture area and in the colors
represents the total umis that are
identified in that capture area
but then you can actually run clustering
algorithms we provide 11 of them
a graph based clustering plus k means
one through ten and this gives you
information about
what types of what spots will cluster
together
by gene expression profile
so there are some very standard text
techniques in in the field of pathology
and the very basic level of it is
annotation by a pathologist which is not
simple
you know people get doctorates in this
but
it's information that can be layered on
top of
your vision data so here are three
sections from one of the cases
of triple negative breast cancer this
has been
annotated by a pathologist
in the green area kind of in the middle
you can see that they're marked with
invasive carcinoma in the lighter green
area which is a little bit covered up by
the blue
you can see that they have annotated
those regions
as ductal carcinoma in situ they've also
identified regions fibrous tissue fat
immune cells which are all extremely
interesting
and to be able to layer this information
on top of what you'll see
in expression space i think is really
cool
so here's just the first section from
this case
and i'm showing you how you can see the
h e image you can then see the
annotated image and then you can see the
clustering laid
on paired with that annotation and
what's really interesting i think in
this
in this visualization is that the
clustering
for this light green red and somewhat
blue tissue or spot actually
pairs up extremely nicely with what
the pathologist annotated as invasive
carcinoma
and these are the kind of images that
i'll be showing from here on out so
please have a look at this and
familiarize yourself
so next i'm going to show how
you can convert these pathologist
annotations into something that can be
ingested by the loop
because right now you are not able
to able to import
the annotations themselves into loop
rather uh those were
something that i did in r but it's very
easy to do
um so you have your h e image
you then have your custom annotations
from uh the pathologist
but then you can associate each spot
with one of those annotations
and you can see that i've done that in
the right hand side now once you assign
a spot which has a barcode
to an annotation that's just considered
a custom cluster
so that is something that loop can
ingest
and so when you put that into loop and
load it up you're then able to do
used loop to do differential expressions
between your
new clusters defined by fibrous tissue
immune tissue ductal carcinoma and c2
and invasive carcinoma
and when we did that we were able to see
that
we pulled out some really interesting
genes many of which
are pretty heavy hitters in the field
of breast cancer study
and it was really gave us
some confidence in what we were seeing
in the clustering versus what the
pathologist annotated
and then you're laying around this whole
another information
about what exactly is happening inside
your tumor
at the microenvironment level
so next i'm going to talk about
integration with
immunofluorescence
so immunofluorescence has been a long
established technique
of being able to visualize protein
expression
in on top of a tissue
so first we took
one of our breast cancer samples uh
we stained it with a cd3 antibody
you can see in red that's the cd3
staining and then
in blue you can see dappy staining for
nuclei
you can then take this image and if it's
and you'll actually take this sample and
run it through the space stranger
pipeline and what you get out
is uh spot information about your cd3
mrna expression so
in this uh we've been capturing we just
made
a um a global signal
for t cells uh because cd3 is very lowly
expressed
in for mrna and this is actually where
the power
of using immunofluorescence and pairing
it with physium comes into play
so you're able to detect both things and
layer them on at once
so you're able to also merge your
protein data
into spots into spot space
so if you have your cd3 channel on your
immunofluorescent image you're then
able to
identify the protein intensity
of each spot now this isn't done in loop
this was done in
r but it's actually very easy to do
so you create a mask and essentially
just
detect what the light intensity is at
each spot
we didn't do any fancy normalization or
anything like that
it is really powerful because then you
can pair that
and correlate it with your mrna
expression
while the cd3 mrna expression for t
cells
is much lower than the protein you can
see that the patterns are very similar
so next you're able to
just like i did before with the cd3 mrna
in classifying things into a high versus
low cd3 expressing
spot space you're able to take your
quantification
of protein levels by
calculating your intensity of light
in spot space you're then able to
make custom clusters out of those so
here i'm just naming my t-cell markers
as
does this spot express a t-cell marker
in protein space
or does it not you're able to then
import those into loop just like i did
with
the custom pathologist annotations
and you're able to do differential
expression and what you can see
is that for spots that have
high cd3 immunofluorescence versus low
immunofluorescence
you can see that it is just chock full
of uh immune representing
gene expression profile and so that's
completely um
expected probably not something that's
shocking but it's a great validation
of the things that we're doing down the
road
now i'd like to talk about
identification of spatially variable
features
um and we'll get into kind of what that
means in just a second
so typically you have your gene
expression
profile and you can have your clustering
represented in umap space like i do
have on the left hand side here and you
can see that
this is for the first section of case
number one
and you can see that you have nice
clustering you have spots that
are tightly packed in tc or umap space
and that indicates that they have
similar gene expression profiles
you then can map that expression and
clustering profiling
back onto your
that went into space ranger and you can
see that you have
some nice distinction of clusters
within this space the things that i'll
probably
pay most attention to here is you can
kind of see the outline of a boot with
the tip
facing left and that is where
the pathologist has it annotated this
sample
as a ductal carcinoma and
but what's really interesting is then if
you say
okay well i identified this
gene iglc2
which is um the constant region of
immunoglobulin uh light chain and
in the recognition phase of hormonal
immunity
this membrane-bound immunoglobulin
serves as a receptor
upon which uh antigens can bind
and uh can trigger the clonal expansion
and differentiation of the lymphocytes
so this would be a
really nice marker of the lymphocyte it
looks very interesting in umph space
you can see that it's expressed in these
few clusters
in red on the kind of lower left-hand
side of your new map
but then when you plot this information
back onto
your onto your tissue you're actually
able to visualize
the expression in tissue space and you
can see this is probably where
the majority of my b cells are residing
and so i think that's pretty cool and
i'm going to get into some
even further expansions on
this on this technique
so in addition to your typical
differential expression uh you might
want to see
what genes are actually spatially
enriched
so we use the surat package and their
function called find
spatially variable features to search
for features that exhibit
a spatial patterning in completely an
absence of any sort of pre-annotation
whether that be clustering cell type or
anything like that
so this method is based on the trendseek
paper
which was published in nature methods in
2018
and it models spatial expression as a
mark point
process and computes a variogram and so
this expression level is dependent on
their spatial location so it takes into
account things
uh genes that are expressed in similar
space
so when we ran this um so just to note
the input to this function is actually
the top 1000
differentially expressed genes so you're
kind of pairing your
gene list down a little bit and that's
really just
to speed the process up a little bit
so here you can see that on the top row
we have two genes that are associated
with immune response in cancer
ccl 19 a cytokine and idha2 which
is another immunogoblin on the bottom
row we see two genes that are enriched
in the region of invasive carcinoma this
migration in invasion enhancer 1 which
is a known gene
associated with cancer metastasis and
then this
slp high gene secretory leukocyte
protease inhibitor
which is upregulated in highly
metastatic triple negative breast cancer
and these cells typically secrete
more slpi and so i'd like to dig into
slpi
a little bit more
so slpei was kind of
deep in the weeds so if you look at um
it was not an obvious candidate when we
ran
just pure differential expression
between clusters
it was actually ranked number 200 in our
cluster-based
differential expression experiments so
i don't know about you but i probably
would have missed this gene
uh back in the days where i was doing a
lot of this sort of research
but when we ran our
spatially enriched gene experiment
slpi was ranked number 15
and i would guarantee that this gene
would be captured after
after this experiment and it seems like
this gene is an
essential part of defining the
microenvironment
of this particular cancer so
on the right here you can see i'm
highlighting where the
slpi gene is expressed in the upper left
hand corner
you can see these two circles where it's
most highly expressed
those correlate with this darker green
clustering you can see in umap space
that is correlated with cluster number
three
uh up in the upper right hand corner of
the umap and then
what i'll be getting into a little bit
more down the road
is that this actually correlates
extremely well
with what we define as ductal cells
when we integrate the single nucleus rna
sequencing data
and this is where we are really taking
things to the next level
by not only seeing your gene expression
information in space
but also being ex being able to
associate that space
with a particular cell type
and that's what i'd like to get into
next so
single nucleus plus vision integration i
think is something that
everyone wants to do and there is a
there are a bunch of groups working on
it and something that we want to enable
so why is single nucleus integration
powerful
so there is just a massive wealth
of single cell and single nucleus data
that is being generated
uh resources like the human cell atlas
i think will be invaluable in
determining you know what makes the cell
a cell
just as the human reference consortium
was invaluable in mapping and defining
the standard for a human reference
genome
so vision captures multiple cells for a
spot it is not a purely single cell
technology
and untangling these mixtures improves
our ability to understand the tumor and
microbio
environment i think is really the
endgame
of what most researchers are interested
in because
it's very all well and good to
understand
where and at what levels your genes are
being expressed
but if you don't have that cell type
information layered on top of it
you know you're you're missing a tp
so the study design of this single
single nucleus rna
integration uh and i'll briefly just
state the reason that we did
single nuclei that we're using fresh
frozen blocks
it's very hard to get single cells
intact out of a frozen block that is
something we're working on though
so these single nuclei came from the
same tumor
as the vision samples they're from the
exact same block
we isolated these single nuclei like i
said we captured 40 000 nuclei
per tumor we then um
this aggregated these samples together
and use
using cell ranger agar and then we
normalized
uh them via harmony um
clusters that were then annotated by our
resident 10 expert scientist uh dr
wyatt mcdonald and then we
did the actual integration uh with sirap
so sarah uses an anchor based workflow
which was introduced in surat b3 that
enables
the probabilistic transfer of
annotations from a reference which is
your single nuclei
to a query set which would be your
vision data
and you can read more about that at
their on their spatial vignette
that they put out earlier this year
so here is a umap representation of
our clustering of our single nuclei
rna sequencing so you can see we've got
a large cluster of t
cells we've got b cells uh we've got
ductal cells stromo cells
we also have tumor cancer cells which
are defined by this
cd163 positive mph but then in the
center
i'd like to draw your attention to our
our tumor cells
but also that they are very close in
umap space
to luminal progenitor cells and i'll be
talking about that
phenomenon just a little bit later
so here you can see the integration of
the single
nuclei rna sequencing data and
identification of spots that are most
likely t cells and that's represented by
this color scale
blue being less likely to be a t cell
red being more likely to be a
t cell on the top row you can see that
outside of
what was normally uh annotated by the
pathologist
as ductal invasive carcinoma um
excuse me of invasive carcinoma
you can see that t-cells reside mostly
on the outside which
isn't surprising but you can see you do
have some invasion
of most likely of tumor t
cell infiltrating lymphocytes or tumor
infrastructure
now you can also do the same with b
cells so b cells reside almost
exclusively outside of
the tumor micro environment
or what's defined as purely invasive
carcinoma
and and that makes sense too and by what
we know in
tumor biology something that's very
interesting though
is that we identified four different
tumor subtypes
and those subtypes are regionally
defined
so you can see that subtype number
what we're calling three that was the
cluster that it was associated with
is kind of in the middle of the
invasive carcinoma so this is just one
slice that i'm showing here
on the upper right hand corner you can
see another tumor subtype
which is very nicely defined on the
right hand side
of the invasive carcinoma then you've
got these
other tumor cells that seem to be spread
throughout the tumor
on the bottom left-hand side and then
you
have another tumor subtype which seems
to be just kind of sparsely expressed
but
regionally well-defined
[Music]
so we've got these tumor subtypes but
what about the how this tumor may have
evolved
and so one of the methodologies to
to be able to identify
how a any cell type may have
originated is to do a trajectory
analysis
so we performed a simple trajectory
analysis using monocle
and discovered some very interesting
aspects of the potential development for
this subject's tumor
so trajectory inference approaches
analyze
genome-wide omics data from many single
cells
and computationally infer the order of
these cells along
some sort of developmental trajectory
so i want to draw your attention um
to this middle group
right here so
here we go um so in the black line
you can see this is actually a graph
that is
inferring what the trajectory may have
been
for this group of cells that are mapped
in umap space
so at the node of this graph at the
bottom
you can see or one of the nodes excuse
me you can see that
this is uh luminal progenitor cells
and so they are seem to be
developing into these tumor cells at the
end
and so deregulation of luminal
progenitor cells
uh are known to be the origin of basal
type triple negative breast cancer
so i think that we've got a really good
snapshot
of how this tumor evolved from the very
beginning
and subtype frequency associated with
uh with is associated with
p53 function and met signaling and
hyperactive
hyperactivity so this is a really
interesting take and discovery for
this single individual's tumor evolution
so these liminal progenitor cells it's
great to identify them but where are
they residing
so you can see on the top row of this
this vision plot you can see that the
liminal progenitor cells
really are residing somewhat on the
outside
of what uh the pathologist has annotated
as invasive carcinoma but i kind of want
to draw your attention
also to these kind of two circle
uh bare spots in the middle where uh
slpi was expressed and you don't see
them there so this is indicative that
those regions probably have more mature
tumor cells and that makes sense
so i mentioned before also that
we are super interested in the phenotype
of the of tumor stem cells and so
it seems like these tumor stem cells
while somewhat rare seem to be at the
tip
of the boot of the invasive carcinoma
and i have always wondered since i've
seen this data
could these be the key for targeting and
therapy
and because and the thing that i found
really interesting
was this entire region this kind of tip
on this on this
boot as you will is
was defined as invasive carcinoma by the
pathologist
but there seems to be a real mixture of
cells going on down there
and could this be some sort of
transition space
um or something that might be a gateway
to therapy
for this individual tumor that's
something that we're really interested
in digging into
so that concludes the section for
integration with single nuclei rna
sequencing data
next i'd just like to kind of give a
shout out to
rahul satija's lab at
new york genome center they put together
an amazing
vignette on processing um
vision spatial data myself and nigel
delaney helped
get this kind of off the ground from the
beginning but they they really ran with
it
and have put out something that is
typical of rahul's lab
in in being an excellent tutorial
this tutorial can be found at this at
this
url it's their vignette spatial vignette
um so in summary
we have shown today uh that the future
of vision brings
a wealth of new applications uh much
more
than what i showed today as we're
integrating a whole bunch of
other applications but we would really
like to know
what you need as researchers to
achieve your goals in science
so feedback would be excellent and i
would really encourage you to
ask questions after my talk which i'll
field
via email and visium enables
the understanding of the tumor
microenvironment at a new level
you get you can integrate
protein-based assays you can integrate
fluorescence-based assays
at the same time while capturing rna-seq
data
in the same spot space on the same
tissue
you can pair these annotations with loop
for processing
so you don't have to do any heavy
computational lifting
and we've designed these data types to
be
paired with real world-class third-party
tools
detection of spatially enriched
expression patterns is one of the things
i'm super excited about and i really
believe that this can lead to new
discoveries
and integration with paired or reference
single cell or single nuclei rna-seq
data
is essential for characterizing a
variety of
different organisms and disorders
so i'd like to thank our 10x team
it is a fantastic group to work with and
also all our outside collaborators
both in pharma and in academia
and at the very end i'd like to just
pitch a webinar that we're having on may
6th
that's being held by wyatt mcdonald who
did the amazing self-type annotation
for us and he'll be presenting a talk
called revolutionizing antibody
discovery
for pharma with single cell approaches
and libra seeks
and that could be and you can register
for this webinar on our website
at this url down below and thank you i'd
like to thank the organizers for
inviting us
and i hope that this was an interesting
insight into the things that we're doing
on the viziium
team and i will field any question via
email
later this week